all right guys
bang bang i have mr nick carter here
with us thank you so much for doing this
sir
my pleasure great to be back episode
appearance number two
with you absolutely let's uh for those
who didn't listen to the first episode
maybe just give us a quick rundown of
your background and then what you're
doing with castle island and with
coinmetrics
sure so um i am a general partner
at castle island ventures we are based
in cambridge
massachusetts we are a venture firm seed
stage primarily
focusing on startups that are building
their businesses on top of public
blockchains
much less of a token focus much more of
focus on
startup equity at the earliest stage and
our view where you could call us
integrationists
we think that public blockchains are
going to become
truly integrated into the financial
services industry there's gonna be a
convergence
we're seeing it happening already we can
talk about it today
uh that's i think one of the causes for
this you know current bull run
we're seeing that convergence happen uh
in real time that's what we're betting
on those the businesses that we fund
um also i co-founded this
uh capital markets data business uh
focusing on blockchain data called
coinmetrics uh that emerged out of an
open source project that i started when
i was still in business school
i was solving my own problem i needed
data for my models i wanted to construct
valuation models
for digital assets i didn't have the
data got together with a friend made the
data turns out a lot of other people
wanted that same data
and then it became a whole business from
there and prior to doing
all of this i was fidelity's first
crypto asset analyst their first
dedicated crypto asset analyst
hired to work on a proprietary fund at
fidelity
and to develop their view develop a kind
of
institutional research perspective on
bitcoin and other digital assets
um i've since left fidelity but that was
my first sort of professional foray into
the crypto industry
got it and so i want to first start off
with uh
you've recently put out a bunch of
awesome research using the koi metrics
data
uh one of the first things that you
talked about was uh everyone is looking
at the twenty thousand dollar
price per bitcoin uh as kind of the
all-time high
you were one of the first people that
started saying wait a second i don't
actually think that's the best way to
measure kind of an all-time high
uh if you look at market cap uh it's
going to be much
lower in a price point somewhere in the
17 500
range talk us through kind of why that
market cap is so important
and then kind of the issuance that
affects the the price per bitcoin
all-time high
well it's certainly valid to look at the
unit price all-time high
i mean if you're an investor that's what
you care about you care about returns
you don't care about the aggregate
economic value of the system
which is what you would refer to market
cap to for
um but the point i was making there was
look if you want to measure bitcoin as a
system for storing wealth
we're actually going to be hitting the
all-time high well before we hit the
unit price all-time high
because the number of bitcoins that
exist
has increased uh in the last three years
i mean it's increased from i think um
you can correct me on this but it's
something like
uh 16 million back in late 2017 today
it's
18.5 million units of bitcoin that
exists so
the market has absorbed all that extra
supply
so if you hold unit price flat and you
have more supply that means the economic
system
the economic significance of the system
is increasing so i was just pointing out
the market cap all-time high is actually
well below
the unit price all-time high that's the
one i'm celebrating
uh you know i'll celebrate the unit
price all-time high too
don't get me wrong much
much more aggressively than i celebrated
the market cap all-time high
uh but it's still an important milestone
you know we can now
credibly say bitcoin as an economic
system is storing more wealth
than ever than ever absolutely
and you also then wrote a piece that
kind of highlighted nine
uh different metrics we're not going to
go through all of them now you've talked
about them with other people
but uh some of them were really
interesting everything from kind of
foreign currencies so non-us dollar
denomination hitting all-time highs even
to
underlying kind of metrics in the system
when you wake up every day and you say i
want to look at how bitcoin's doing what
do you actually
look at are you looking at unit price
are you looking at
other metrics like what does nick carter
wake up every day and the first three or
four metrics that you check
you're probably the first person to ever
ask me that believe it or not
which is crazy because you know i'm
looking at this data all the time
you know not saying i have a special
purchase on the data or anything
but uh i've been you know drowning in
crypto data for years and years now uh
it's literally part of the reason
coinmetrics exists i had a rapacious
demand
for more crypto data you know so like
i take advantage of that i'll go to the
analysts and the engineers all the time
and ask for
for some new data feed it's amazing i
recommend that everybody starts a data
company
highly highly recommended you get a ton
of access to data
you're an investor you invest in data
companies too
uh you know it's very useful um there's
so much though there's so so so much
the crypto industry is the most
data-rich industry
in capital markets in my opinion because
these are open transparent ledgers
that's the interesting
compelling thing about them every
transaction is transparent that doesn't
mean we know who's making every
transaction
but it does mean that we can audit the
money supply to the last satoshi
we can find out what the velocity is in
the most granular
way the measures of the broad money
supply for dollars
those are all kind of survey-based like
there's a lot of estimates involved
the you know federal reserve bank of st
louis publishes all this great data on
the fred website
they don't really know how many dollars
exist probably not even to the last
billion
uh so you know the availability and the
abundance of data in
crypto and bitcoin is really amazing i'm
not even answering your question
um the the problem probably the the
answer is it depends what i'm interested
in
on that particular day however typically
start with coinmetrics
look at adjusted transaction value for
bitcoin and a whole bunch of other
assets you know to me that's really the
key key thing
how much value are these value
conveyance systems
settling how does that compare to the
other settlement networks to the other
payment networks
um i'll look at the supply of stable
coins uh the distribution of stable
coins
uh what's happening are they contracting
are they increasing they're almost
always increasing
are looking at measures of dispersion
what is the distribution of ownership
on these blockchains is it contracting
is is it getting more distributed
more distributed is good that means
there's more people that are holding
units
that's one of the metrics that i had in
that nine charts piece
i'd look at that for bitcoin ethereum uh
you know i want to see
um you know what kinds of holders are
are owning these digital assets are they
small are they whole typically is it
sort of amounts that are consistent with
retail investors
you know where is the supply if you
divide it up by the
the size of supply and various addresses
where is that supply
um you know how is it broken up uh is
bitcoin mostly being held by whales or
you know smaller individuals
encouragingly
the amount of bitcoin that's held in
smaller wallets is growing all the time
which is a great sign for me and then
i'll look at um the more
you know exchange-related metrics i'll
recommend the blocks
data dashboard i don't know if you've
seen this it's really really high
quality they aggregate a ton of data
coin metrics
and market data uh all sorts of i'll
look at the
um the premium on the grayscale product
that certainly uh interesting
information in there i'll look at the
whether we're in contango or back
radiation or look at the futures markets
uh look at the volumes on the various
exchanges in particular
cme um so you know there's a ton
i mean sometimes i you know recently i
spent a week
just looking at doing analytics data
trying to understand
uh d5 what's happening on d5 who's using
what how many
users are there what's the liquidity on
uniswap
um so it depends but for whatever
it is that i need there is a data source
usually free
which is the most amazing thing about
this industry the abundance of data is
incredible
when you look at the grayscale gbtc
premium what are you trying to
understand there or kind of what if it's
larger or smaller on any given day what
are kind of the things that you think
about
well there's two things that affect the
premium right one thing
is what happened six months ago because
the product the trust you create new
units takes six months to mature and
then you can sell it
so this is trade that's constantly
occurring i'm sure you talked about on
the show
you know certain firms will borrow
bitcoin or they'll hit their exposure
somehow
they'll create units of the gbdc trust
at net asset value
and then six months later they can sell
it at market price so what happens today
is you know partially a function of what
happened six months ago how many units
of the trust were created
so it's a noisy metric the premium is
because the other metric
that affects the premium is how much
retail investor enthusiasm
is there for gbdc on these brokerages
like schwab fidelity etc uh
and so those two things are smashed into
a single metric which is a premium
which makes them hard to disentangle but
for me
a persistent premium on the gbdc product
even though every fund and their uncle
is doing this trade constantly creating
new units and selling them off at nav
even though there's that constant cell
pressure from the creation of units of
the fund
the persistent premium shows me there's
still
retail investor strong retail investor
demand for this financialized version of
bitcoin
either because they want to hold it in a
tax advantaged way
or because it's just convenient to hold
bitcoin on their brokerage where they
already have an account where they
already hold their equities
so and to me like the kind of people
that buy gbdc is
different profile from from you and me i
mean
i own some gbdc it's very useful but you
know
i definitely own more spot bitcoin than
i own gbdc
you know but the kind of people that are
going to put their portfolio in gbdc are
people that maybe
don't have the energy and enthusiasm to
learn what a full node is
they don't care they just want exposure
to the financial asset bitcoin
to me that's probably an older
demographic probably a slightly
wealthier demographic
people that are they just want to
interact with the brokerage that they
trust they don't want to make an account
on coinbase
uh or any of the spot exchanges and so
that pressure to me
if this market's being led by by gbdc
and there's some evidence that it is
uh that pressure is is quite good that's
sort of a more traditional
um you know set of investors there's a
lot more capital there
than there is from from millennials you
know
yeah one of the things that really
fascinating to me about that grayscale
product is
that arbitrage trade obviously is a huge
uh financial incentive for people to get
exposure and so
for those that don't know essentially uh
there's a number of different ways that
you can
arb the premium uh everything from you
can just lock in the premium
uh through hedging or you can actually
take the bitcoin price risk plus the
premium capture
uh by contributing kind of in-kind
bitcoin or whatever
what's interesting though is they are
exploding in
assets uh under management and it feels
like
uh you know we could be pushing towards
uh a liquidity crunch
uh where just like literally there is so
much bitcoin being bought up
uh that nobody wants to sell at lower
prices there's not any bitcoin to be
sold because the incoming supply has
been cut in half
and so you actually get this like really
weird
um almost parabolic like price movement
or something
similar to that but it's not driven by
like retail fomo it's literally just by
market structure of there not being
enough liquid
bitcoin and the financial incentive is
so large in
uh that gbt arbitrage trade that has
like a significant impact do you
see that happening or is that more yeah
theoretically that could happen but but
not likely
yeah people keep tossing around the
phrase sell side liquidity crisis
which just cracks me up so much um i
mean the level of creation of
new units of gbdc is astonishing
i mean they're tacking on hundreds of
millions of dollars of bitcoin a day
they passed 10 billion i think maybe
yesterday
they're well above it now i mean the
product is
just going gangbusters um it's really
not that
implausible to imagine a world where um
grayscale becomes a hundred billion
dollar asset manager
i mean you know an asset manager on that
top tier with with other
you know traditional asset managers um
you know one thing i will note though is
that it's impossible to kind of run out
of bitcoin you just sort of
reprice the units um as as
enthusiasm for the asset grows but one
trend that we notice
is in bull runs the active supply which
is liquid and market available
increases the unit price drags up
that bitcoin that's held you know in
long-term cold storage
so you know fundamental it's the same
thing that happens in gold
actually believe it or not when the unit
price of gold goes up
enough people will melt down their gold
jewelry they will sell their investment
gold
this is gold which is semi-market
relevant but it's not on the market
the unit price of gold goes up enough
that gold that's sort of held in cold
storage so to speak
that can become market relevant again it
can get recycled into the market
we see the same thing with bitcoin
bitcoin's sort of one year active supply
though
is at a low i mean it's really
comparatively low
so i think this you know this
new cycle that we're seems like we're
entering here will
drag a lot of that inner bitcoin back
onto the market
um so that's kind of the mechanism i see
here but there's latency it takes a
while you know people have to go to
their safety deposit box and
you know you do their multi-sig protocol
to get that bitcoin to be liquid again
and of course a lot of you know
long-term holders aren't interested at
selling at current prices
maybe they're only interested in selling
at 40 50 000 but
i think that's really the mechanism to
keep an eye on seeing these older coins
seeing if they're coming back onto the
market or not
i'm going to keep a really close watch
on that got it
and so obviously that uh that one year
kind of 12 month
uh you know metric around what hasn't
moved i think the high i've seen so far
is around 63 percent give or take
um what is the metric you look at or the
time frame you look at to determine
um you know what won't come into the
market so regardless of price
uh is it 10 20 of bitcoin is it 50
30 like how do you think about what is
the amount of bitcoin that either is
lost um as one thing that so never come
into the market
or two it's held by such strong hands
that regardless of price it's just not
gonna come back onto the market is that
a five-year
kind of hasn't moved longer how do you
think about that
yeah i would use five-year uh five-year
in-art supply is the default uh
heuristic there
that's the threshold that coinmetrics
picked they were they created this
this measure of free float uh supply
uh and you you just kind of have to pick
an arbitrary number at a certain point
they wanted it to be
standardized across many crypto assets
so they picked the five year
uh interestingly theorem just turned
five so
um according to that metric ethereum
became their free float supply declined
substantially when they hit that
anniversary
um but yeah i would pick the five year
for that um my other rule of thumb would
be about
20 of bitcoin we can presume is lost or
truly inert
of course it's not verifiably lost we
did do an analysis of the bitcoins that
we know
for sure cannot exist are provably lost
they were either burned there was a
coinbase output that the miner failed to
claim
which has happened on certain uh of you
know certain
periods historically you can look at
bitcoin
that is included in op return outputs
which is provably unspendable
so there are categories of bitcoin which
we can know for sure
cannot be spent or lost you know bitcoin
that just gets bricked
um but then the much larger categories
bitcoins that we're presuming
are lost but of course you know
satoshi's bitcoins
they can come back online there's
nothing preventing them
we're just assuming that whoever
controls those keys is not interested in
ever
bringing them onto the market given that
they've never really moved any of them
they're still sitting in their coinbase
outputs of 50 a piece
you know a few thousand outputs like
that never moved
but of course we're just assuming that
they're completely
liquid and they're not market relevant
it's not inconceivable they'd come back
would that be a bullish or bearish move
or are you indifferent to whether those
coins moved
i think the market can absorb a million
bitcoins
i think those coins started to move they
got all deposited on coinbase
a lot of people would pile into coinbase
to buy satoshi coins
that would be some classic coins right i
would do that
so i think they would get bought up i
probably there'd be some price impact
however the bearish part of that i would
say would be that
you know clearly the entity satoshi has
returned
and is selling out uh their coins
so to me just symbolically it would be
bearish because it
implies that you know satoshi has lost
faith or they're just not interested in
being involved anymore i don't think
it'll ever happen
but that would be the bearish element
for me yeah you mentioned earlier defy
and you'd done kind of a pretty deep
dive there what did you find when you
went and did that uh analysis
i recently wrote a chapter of a book on
defy
for a law professor her book is on open
banking
i told her look open banking is
interesting for sure
but d5 is more open than open banking
and uh she asked me to write a chapter
on it and i'm not a defy authority per
se
right you know me you know i'm not a
huge uh investor in d5 we
you know we have looked at d5 deals for
sure as a fund
um but i i figured i owed it to the
industry to get smart about d5 i don't
want to be
ignorant about one of the more explosive
trends
um so i would say i divide d5 mentally
into two
different interrelated phenomena so one
is
the d5 infrastructure which is an
infrastructure
which permits a variety of financial
transactions swaps
interest rate swaps permissionless
leverage
uh some people call it lending i don't
necessarily consider what happens on d5
to be lending in the
you know classic bank uh you know
maturity transformation sense
um that infrastructure is very
sophisticated of course
there's you know bugs and exploits but
it it really has come a long way
and then you have these sort of clinical
applications which are really
i would say the financial products which
are available to trade and get exposure
to
in defy which are the pseudo equity
tokens
you know the comps the uniswaps the
curves
the wifis of the world the things that
people actually trade
in d5 and those i probably have a lot
more questions about
about the long-term value cruel
potential of a pseudoequity is what i
call it
because it has some of the features of
equity
you know you have some control rights
some governance rights
and you have an implied claim on certain
cash flows right
if you own uniswap or comp you might
anticipate that the governance would
malleate that system
such that the tokens would get a
plausible claim on cash flows whether
it's a burn
a dividend a distribution whatever i
think that's kind of implied
um you know this is very incipient it's
very new
there's a lot that needs to be hashed
out how does the governance work
what are the securities regulators going
to say about if anything
um you know can this be a sustainable
model etc
so that's kind of my 50 000 view after a
long period of looking at d5 very
seriously
um you know mainly from a data driven
perspective the infrastructure is
at a very impressive state of maturity
honestly and
um the ux of using d5 in some cases far
surpasses
uh using c5 especially for for trading
uh but um still open questions
as it pertains to you know the the d5
tokens
and when you mentioned the lending
component of this are you talking about
uh kind of this like yield farming or
are you talking about something else
no i would say um lending
you know in the sense that you might um
get a loan on compound
for instance so you know you deposit
some
some usdc and then you know you're
earning some interest for that
and and the reason i say it's not it has
dis analogies
to banking is that there isn't really
any credit
um you know occurring i mean there's no
credit creation
right because i don't know who my
counterparty is i'm just interacting
with a pool of capital
right in commercial banking you know the
bank
is performing diligence on
the person they're giving a mortgage to
for instance right so the bank is just
the intermediary between the savers the
deposit funds
and then between the businesses and the
individuals that they lend to
but they're performing diligence and if
that you know loan goes bad
and someone defaults on the loan they
have recourse they can claim your house
they can claim your car
they can claim your collateral you know
whatever you've stumped up
uh so that doesn't exist in defy land
there's no real world law enforcement
legalese recourse if a defy loan goes
bad so you're really lending against
liquid collateral
all of the time so jake travinsky has
talked about this
this idea is not original to me i highly
recommend the blog post he wrote about
it on bankless
but the point is you know there's no
credit creation because there's no like
persistent identity in defy
and there's no real ability to get
recourse if someone
you know runs off with an under
collateralized loan
yeah one of the other things i wanted to
talk about uh is there was a recent blog
post written by jesse feldler
who uh i think most of us you know
really respect from a macroeconomic
standpoint
um and an investment standpoint uh but
he basically said don't ask me about
bitcoin and he
rehashed depending on who you asked uh
kind of critiques from 2013 or 2017.
i saw you responded on twitter uh maybe
just walk
through um kind of how do you think
about
people who are very well known in the
finance world
who maybe either one haven't done the
work yet but kind of come out
as a critic or two
have done work but don't yet kind of get
to the point of
understanding uh or agreement that maybe
you and i have
like is that something where we should
focus on
like let's go find all those people and
kind of berate them until they they
they pay attention is it something like
we just have to accept that that's gonna
be be a trend like how do you just view
that part of uh
of maybe where we are in the market
cycles yeah my opinion on this has
evolved
for sure i mean what you know part of
our job as capital allocators
is talking to these larger pools of
capital that
might allocate to our vehicles and
educating them
about the industry and you've done a
great job of this
and this is something that i would say
most people
active in the sort of capital management
side of this business
do whether it's a crypto hedge fund
crypto venture fund
you know people managing you know
passive investment products
is perform this continuous education
process
because there's still this enormous golf
and understanding so
you know most people in our shoes will
be intimately familiar with the process
of going to someone who's
totally new to the industries maybe
curious about it
but they haven't really given any real
thought to it they don't really
understand it as an investment asset
and coaching them up through that
process of discovery but what i would
say
is a necessary condition for that to be
successful has to be some
you know genuine enthusiasm or at least
a curiosity for the asset class
um if you know it looks like jesse in
this case
is sort of you know negatively disposed
towards the industry
um my current view on that is some
people are probably not going to come
around regardless i mean
it may be that they lack the humility to
publicly change their opinion on
something
or they just you know are fundamentally
opposed to crypto for philosophical or
ideological reasons
and so i don't think they can
necessarily be converted i focus my
current energy on people that are
curious that are open-minded there's an
unlimited supply of those people
uh you know especially on wall street i
mean lots of people
you know that i talk to haven't thought
about crypto over three years or so
since 2017. now is an opportune time to
go to them and say hey look it's back
you know
uh maybe you should be rethinking your
prior assumptions about the industry and
i always
have a lot of success doing that i mean
i gave a talk at a
enormous financial institutions the
other day and
uh you know i won't say which one but
the
my moderator was working on private
blockchains that was part of
their mandate which is kind of crazy to
me in 2020 private blockchains
but uh that's fine and after the talk
she told me that she'd gone home the
night before and bought bitcoin for the
very first time
you know even though her focus was much
more on the enterprise blockchain side
so you know we can still make ground
with these people
what's happening in bitcoin is not that
difficult to comprehend i think if you
if you zoom out you're willing to take a
longer term view
you know historical view of monetary
assets and
currencies and so on uh it's just about
contextualizing in the right way
but as i said your counterparty has to
be
somewhat open-minded for that process to
work so you got to pick your battles
basically
for sure and speaking of open-minded uh
if you had asked me
up until last week ray dalio would have
fallen in the
um you know we agree on all the problems
we don't agree on the solution and he
doesn't sound very open-minded
but he had this thread on twitter where
he basically said look you know
maybe i'm missing something and if
somebody wants to educate me on it then
i'm open to being uh having my my mind
changed
and what was so fascinating to me was
one to say that publicly
uh is a pretty big deal and goes to the
humility you described uh but also
there's this element of um it almost
feels like
whale hunting a little bit right like
paul tudor jones okay like he's it
right stanley drunken miller he's it the
last one standing to some degree
is uh ray dalio right like it feels like
okay if somebody gets dalio to
kind of capitulate and say you know what
this is real then there's almost
no wall street legend left to kind of go
capture in the mythical game of like you
know
convincing people of bitcoin right we
still warren buffett but i don't think
he's ever going to come around
but rey's a particularly interesting
case right as you
implied earlier in the episode because
he does have this view that we have an
enormous debt overhang
dare i say a debt crisis in front of us
debt to gdp ratios are off the charts
you know
you look at monetary issuance in the
long term it correlates with inflation
one way or another
ray has made all these points he's as
nervous as anybody is
about the macroeconomic and monetary
environment
he's got this long-term historical view
he doesn't think the reserve currency
status lasts forever
i mean all of the intellectual toolkit
is there for sure
i mean i was impressed that he would say
that publicly like hey
you know i'm open-minded having my mind
changed he's in his 70s right i mean
he's still learning in his 70s that's
impressive
uh i've learned a ton from ray uh his
book big debt crisis
highly recommended principles i found to
be a little bit dry honestly
uh but you know rey is there
as far as having all that sort of those
prior
views that would make you amenable to
contemplating bitcoin as an investment
um whether or not he he makes it the
final 10
of the way there i guess we'll see yeah
and it seemed like
uh price was playing into some of the
questioning of maybe i'm missing
something
um but i've seen you tweet about this
idea of like this is like the quietest
bull market of all time um and it's just
this quiet rally uh
you know if you go out on the street and
you ask somebody what's the price of
bitcoin
uh 100 of people won't know where it is
uh but 100
won't think it's you know going to zero
or near zero you'll get kind of a mixed
reaction
but you would have expected for an asset
that um
has kind of rallied you know 500 plus
percent uh
off the bottom uh within a relatively
short period of time in less than two
years
um there would be much more fanfare
especially for an asset that is uh
generally controversial in uh financial
circles right there's uh
um a uh a media person once said to me
if i bring the 10 smartest people i know
and i put them in a room
and i leave and i say you know basically
debate bitcoin i'll come back five will
be on one side five will be on the other
the only difference is with this asset
that uh each side will think the other
side is complete idiot for what they
believe like
it's just got some emotional kind of
charge to it
how do you think about the media
coverage kind of that quiet rally
feel to this is this just natural for
the start of a bull market
and kind of you know let's be careful
what we wish for because there will be
this massive
fomo and retail excitement later or is
this maybe
signaling that this time it might be
different when it comes to
the excitement around the price
appreciation
uh that's kind of underway yeah and
i think the first thing to to remember
is
a lot of people will have become
familiar with bitcoin
that first time around in 2017. so
if they hear about bitcoin again they're
not necessarily going to google bitcoin
this time right so that the faithfulness
of that proxy metric you know
google searches for bitcoin whatever it
is you you want the metric to be
that metric may not be tracking the real
world adoption of bitcoin
uh or even interest in bitcoin that
closely so and
i would venture that that's the case you
know you learn about something new for
the first time
um you know you don't think about it for
a few years you return to it a few years
later you're not necessarily going
through that same initial process again
so i would question the kind of google
trends metric but
you're right i mean it's it's fairly
quiet all things considered
which is incredibly refreshing by the
way
uh you know in 2017 my predominant
uh you know emotion with regards to the
market was probably disgust i mean
you know it was exciting of course but
it was tainted by this misallocation of
capital
and the ico drama which was
causing so much misallocation and of
course you know most of those icos are
defunct now uh so you know i wasn't that
excited by it
of course it was you know structurally
exciting but i was very worried about
how enduring it would be
uh if bitcoin was just this pass-through
asset that was being used to buy icos or
buy sort of long-tail altcoins for
instance
today i think you know bitcoin rallying
and becoming monetized into this
you know genuine global macro asset
that's exciting if you care about
interest rates
and you know the underlying story of
bitcoin and that long-term
multi-decade journey that we're on it's
probably less exciting to your average
retail investor that is looking for
you know a quick flip or a pump you know
like they were excited by
the potential of icos and altcoins in
2017
probably less excited by bitcoin
continuing to study march up
upward which is fine the other thing a
lot of people got terribly burned
in 2017 2018 and they sort of wrote off
the asset class
so some people will just have decided to
never participate
ever again uh you know i so there's
there's definitely some casualties of
the bear market too
people that were active and making noise
in 2017 that aren't active here
but i don't mind the you know the more
quiet uh
phase that we're in that to me that's
consistent with
you know family offices getting exposure
rich individuals that are worried they
need a hedge against
you know the legal system failure or
the failure of a monetary system you
know this is consistent with some of
those larger
allocators they don't necessarily want
to announce their purchases they may
never publicly talk about them
that's what we should want bitcoin is a
tool for wealth preservation
in potentially you know dangerous or
extenuating circumstances
a lot of the classic bitcoin allocators
have no incentive to ever discuss their
position
totally fine with me absolutely
talk a little bit about the castle
island portfolio
um obviously each company is a little
different and um you can only share so
much but
what are you excited about in the
portfolio or what are some of the
updates that you guys have had
that you think people would enjoy
hearing about
well um as i said our main focus is
financial market infrastructure although
that's not our sole focus
and any of our businesses which involve
brokerage or intermediation
that give people access points to
bitcoin to digital assets
all of those metrics are up and to the
right i'm sure that's the case
really across the board and any of these
brokers but
it's just fascinating to get that on the
ground view of adoption
i mean the the current rally is is
really
is is like quite something in terms of
traction at new
new exchanges new brokers um one
kind of structural factor that i'm
really interested in tracking very
closely investing in
would be this kind of crypto
dollarization idea
and now bitcoiners may not like me for
talking about this because it doesn't
have that much to do with bitcoin
although it is related
um is this idea that you know public
blockchains
are actually a really great alternative
infrastructure for settlements and for
payments that is completely
not dependent on the corresponding
banking system and people thought
you would use stable coins or you know
other crypto tokens for remittance
purposes
they've thought this for the last half
decade it's only starting to happen now
i mean you know that was kind of the
ripple hypothesis people didn't really
want to use
a volatile asset for payments
you know there have been tons and tons
of coins that people thought would be
for good for payment purposes
i think stable coins or crypto dollars
whatever you want to call them
those actually really are suitable for
that because they
you know alleviate that volatility
concern uh they're in theory
most of them are redeemable for real
dollars and bank accounts somewhere
uh and empirically we're seeing public
blockchains get taken over
by stablecoins i mean i believe
stablecoins are doing more transactional
value than either bitcoin or ethereum
um so in a certain sense the blockchains
themselves are getting dollarized
the same way that actual jurisdictions
get dollarized
and what i think is happening here is
that with stablecoins this is
interesting arbitrage where you get
access to credible
sort of the us banking system you get
access to that
in an offshore way you know in places
where maybe you don't
have access to dollars at all and you
know if you look at these historical
dollarization events
they had to happen with physical dollars
in the past and that was always a
constraint
you didn't have enough bills you didn't
have the right to nominations bills
if you use digital dollars crypto
dollars that's not a constraint at all
you can seamlessly import as many
as you like it just becomes more of a ux
challenge and getting people
up to date on the technological uh kind
of usage modes
um but so that's one thing i'm tracking
that's one thing we're investing in
and i think that's going to be an
enormous phenomenon
i think fundamentally crypto is actually
pretty good for the dollar
people think it's bad for the dollar i
think it's good for the dollar
i think it means that it's a
distribution point four dollars to the
general public
worldwide i think it's gonna accelerate
the collapse of a lot of those sovereign
currencies that can't stack up
against the dollar i know we give the
doll a lot of stick but it's
you know probably one of the soundest of
all the sovereign currencies at least
is this what china you think is trying
to do is basically
uh they identify that this is a path
that the dollar could take
and their belief is if they can uh kind
of beat the dollar to the punch if you
will
uh and have the nation state actually
behind the push
uh maybe they can have their currency uh
become that
crypto uh currency if you will or kind
of nation state currency adopted
globally
rather than the dollar or do you think
that there might be more kind of the
surveillance and other things uh is
driving their interest in
a lot of this yeah and you see they they
kind of beat the us to the punch in
terms of actually launching
a cbdc so to speak but of course
the big big difference between the dc ep
which is the chinese cbdc system
and a kind of private sector crypto
dollar is
that crypto dollar comes with pretty
good privacy assurances
it comes with uh some fair stipulations
against just having your dollars seized
arbitrarily you know um if you look at
the
you look empirically at how many times
um usdc freezes accounts it's very rare
it's very sparing and it's only i
believe if they get a letter from a
judge or from a court or something like
that
uh with the chinese digital currency you
have no such assurances
uh you in you'd imagine that that would
ultimately be bundled with surveillance
facility
um and you know the question is will
that be adopted i think it could totally
be adopted as part of sort of the belt
and road initiative
uh as a tool of you know surveillance i
mean if you control
your population's spending output what
they can spend money on
you basically control them completely uh
so if you're a
you know a wannabe despot in you know
some country somewhere and you want
tools of surveillance
you could maybe introduce a chinese
digital currency
to your population and sell them on the
convenience
while also backdooring in a measure of
control and surveillance
uh so you know that could be a package
that china chooses to export
um you know to its strategic partners
globally which seems to be growing by
the day
um but you know a a crypto dollar
private sector crypto dollar that we've
seen
the fundamental value proposition there
is actually transactional autonomy
you know the ability to transact freely
without constraints
of course there's no replacement for
bitcoin in terms of transactional
autonomy the crypto dollars are pretty
good
uh and you know you get fair privacy
with them not every transaction is
surveilled
only the transactions recruit creating
or redeeming that stable coin
with the ultimate issuer those are the
ones where this kind of kyc obligations
the unhosted wallet transactions the
kind of peer-to-peer on-chain
transactions
there's no kyc obligation there so they
couldn't they kind of look structurally
similar
you know they look cosmetically similar
but they couldn't be more different
in terms of what they empower users to
do
opposite ends of the spectrum there yeah
when we look forward to uh kind of the
crypto industry in general whether it's
equity uh bitcoin cbdc's etc
what are you paying attention to from a
milestone standpoint over maybe the next
two or three years are there specific
things that you're like
you know it would be a big deal if x
happened and i'll give you an example
like maybe a bitcoin etf
that would cause an inflection point for
uh bitcoin and crypto overall are there
other things that you would kind of put
in that bucket that you're that you're
kind of awaiting yeah bitcoin etf would
obviously that's
we've been waiting for that for what
half a decade now um
i certainly thought we would come
earlier
we're really the the regulators running
out the clock on that one we'll see what
happens there
um i think the ability to buy bitcoin
spot bitcoin and withdraw at a major
brokerage
a major kind of retail brokerage in the
us would be colossal
um maybe even more so than etf because
you know the withdrawal functionality is
key
paypal could could do that they could
layer on the withdrawal
that would be key the real you know the
only true way to own bitcoin is to know
the keys
and to own it on chain um something else
would be
changes to the tax treatment of bitcoin
for instance
a de minimis exemption for transactions
such that you don't have to recognize a
capital gains
whenever you make a bitcoin when you buy
something with bitcoin
in theory under the way that the irs
treats bitcoin
treat it like property you have to
recognize the capital gain if bitcoin
has changed in price
since the time that you bought it and
the time that you're spending on
something
my tax returns are total mess as a
result of that because
you have to look at when you acquired
that unit of bitcoin
you see what you spend it on see if the
price change then recognize that capital
gain it's terrible
um potentially you know re-classing
bitcoin
as a currency as opposed to
a former property for tax purposes that
would
be really interesting to see i don't
know if we'll get it
um as far as you know commodities
regulation or securities regulation
bitcoin is already
very well understood by the cftc they
consider it to be a commodity no
structural change needed there
um those are those are kind of the big
things i'm looking forward
um obviously there's sort of price and
market cap milestones
um but yeah we still have a long ways to
go in terms of market infrastructure
with an etf being the the key thing
um i'd be interested in seeing stable
coins issued against
base money so seeing the full
hybridization
of central bank currency and
stable coin issuance uh to my knowledge
that
isn't really occurring yet i mean when
you use a stable coin
the reserve tends to be commercial bank
liabilities right but what if you could
disintermediate the commercial banks
and have an entity issue stable coins
directly against base money which is a
liability of the central bank
to me that's quite interesting um so i
would like to see that happen
at some point that'd be something else
i'm looking forward to other than that
are there specific types of companies or
some
uh sort of products that you guys are
out on the hunt for and
if somebody listening is building it
they should reach out to you guys
yeah so anything that pertains to
making the experience of using digital
assets
more convenient for regular folks
whether that's brokerage key management
exchange
custody any of that we're always on the
hunt for those
anyone that's building a new exchange in
some jurisdiction that's underserved
you know that's a big focus for us right
now this is a global phenomenon
not just us it is giving people the
opportunity
to opt out of their local monetary
regime
opt-in to either a dollar token
or bitcoin uh so anybody that's bringing
those assurances
to jurisdictions don't have great
connectivity to the crypto industry
we're absolutely looking at those and
then anybody that's using
you know blockchains an interesting and
scalable way you know so we look at
startups that are using
uh the blockchain for time stamping or
proof of publication purposes
for a variety of you know non-financial
use cases
i know people say it's primarily a
financial phenomenon i say that too
but there are also pretty valid
non-financial use cases
in order to just enhance trust in you
know supply chain processes for instance
to prove that something exists at a
certain point in time
uh so those would all be categories of
things that we're sort of actively
looking at
yeah i love those where can we send
people to uh find you on the internet or
read some of the stuff that you've been
writing
i'm on medium i don't know exactly what
my username is
um just search nick carter the uh the
archive of all of my content is my
personal website nickcarter.info that's
where everything is
and then of course our firm's website is
castleisland.vc.victorcharley
and you can obviously find me on twitter
not hard to find on there
awesome man listen thank you so much for
doing this uh you have been absolutely
killing it
and uh every time you write something i
run to read it because it makes
people think so we'll have to do this
again in the future
thanks anthony